اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من طوباس اهلا بكم
غارات اسرائيليه مكثفه على قطاع غزه ادت
الى سقوط شهداء وجرحى في مناطق متفرقه كما
دمر الاحتلال مساجد عده من بينها المسجد
العمري التاريخي الكبير بمدينه غزه من
جهتها حذرت وزاره الصحه من خطر انتشار
المجاعه والاوبئه بين النازحين وقالت ان
من خرجوا عبر معبر رفح لا يتعدون 400 مصاب
من اصل اكثر من 46 ال انفجار في منطقه تل
ابيب جراء اطلاق كتائب القسام صاروخين دون
اعتراضهما في حين اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
مقتل ثلاثه من ضباطه في معارك بغزه وسحب
تعزيزات دفاعيه من المستوطنات القريبه من
القطاع في وقت اعلنت فيه كتائب القسام
احباط المقاومه لمحاوله اسرائيلي اليوم
لتحرير جندي اسرائيلي محتجز لديها وفي
الضفه الغربيه شهداء وعدد من الجرحى برصاص
قوات الاحتلال في مخيم الفارعه بطوباس كما
اصيب اخرون خلال اقتحاماتها عددا من المدن
والبلدات في حين عززت الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وجودها في محيط البلده القديمه بالقدس
وفرضت قيودا صارمه على دخول المصلين الى
المسجد الاقصى وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
يقول للحكومه الاسرائيليه ان عدد الضحايا
مازال مرتفعا للغايه وشدد على ضروره
سماحها بدخول المساعدات الى غزه كما نقل
موقع بوليتيكو عن ثلاثه مسؤولين في تل
ابيب ان اداره الرئيس الامريكي امهلت
اسرائيل حتى نهايه العام لانهاء حربها على
حماس الى
اللقاء